in this video we'll talk about
traveler's diarrhea traveler's diarrhea
is a digestive tract disorder that
commonly causes loose tools and abnormal
cramps
people who travel all across the world
might have encountered this kind of
traveler's diarrhea situation it is
caused by eating contaminated food
outside or drinking contaminated water
and the key causative organism for
travellers diarrhea ranges from virus
bacteria or even could be parasites
now you have increased risk of
developing a traveler's diarrhea when
you visit a place
where the climate and the sanitary
conditions are very different from the
conditions at your home
especially many travelers who visit in
the developing countries
might get this kind of travel travelers
diarrhea especially when they're
indulging themselves to try
street foods and not having water from a
good sources this street food might look
really lucrative and tasty but it might
have
many microorganisms bacteria and spores
of them
that can cause things like traveller's
diarrhea another major source is
drinking water if the water is not
coming from a reliable source in third
world countries where the sanitary
condition is not that great
there could be contaminations in the
water as well
let's talk about what are the
microorganisms that can cause travelers
diarrhea and what are the signs and
symptoms
there are several microorganisms which
are responsible for travelers diarrhea
which includes
enterotoxicogenic e coli
shigella and salmonella species
campylobacter jejuni etc
it can be caused due to protozoans like
giardia
also there are viruses which can cause
travelers diarrhea like rotavirus
norovirus
now
apart from salmon apart from shigella
and campylobacter none of these
organisms can cause a bloody diarrhea
now toxins produced by many of these
bacteria leads to the symptoms
that leads us to the signs and symptoms
of traveler's diarrhea it involves
abrupt onset of
stool
at least passage of stool three or more
times in a day and generally you have a
loosed watery stool that means diarrhea
right
abdominal cramps nausea vomiting are
pretty common sometimes the infection
might be
a bit strong and it can lead to fever
like symptoms
in this situation body loses a lot of
water because lot of water is lost with
the stool that means oral rehydration
therapy could be very useful to maintain
the electrolyte and salt balance in the
body and overall drinking a lot of water
and staying hydrated would really help
in most of the cases antibiotics would
work because bacteria is the major cause
of this kind of traveler's diarrhea so
with the antibiotic bacterias would be
killed and your body would recover
slowly along with that some amount of
probiotic would help to establish the
healthy bacterial composition in your
gut
now
there are several types of travellers
diarrhea caused by several types of
microorganisms if it is untreated then a
bacterial
diarrhea can generally recover within
uh
three to seven days
whereas a viral diarrhea lasts for two
to three days and a protozoonal diarrhea
might
persist for a month
so proper treatment for this is required
in order to treat
antibiotics is one of the option at the
same time there would be ors and
rehydration therapy which can maintain
the body's fluid balance and keep you
little bit stronger in this situation
in case of viral
diarrhea there is no other specific
medications
in case of
protozoa mediated diarrhea different
medications other than antibiotics has
to be used for treatment purposes
and with these treatment options things
can get back better within like 2-3 days
the risk of travellers diarrhea is very
high in young and the old people because
they don't have very good immune system
also if you are taking
uh proton pump inhibitors which reduce
your gastric acidity that can also
increase the chances of travellers
diarrhea because gastric acidity or
gastric acid is one of the thing that
kills many of the pathogen that
get gets inside our body with the food
or water
so that could be one of the reason as
well
so in order to prevent this kind of
unexpected traveler's diarrhea you
should always eat from reliable sources
and also drink from reliable sources
keeping a packet of ors with you might
help in this kind of travel journey
also the notes and flashcards associated
with many topics are found in my
facebook page
my facebook page contains a lot of
dynamic notes and flashcard with help
which helps in revision
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel on
patreon my courses are present in an
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform using my code ap 10
can give you 10 percent discount you can
follow me on social media feel free to
connect i would be really happy to help
thank you